i was intending to ask the russian
ambassador to confirm
on the record
that the russian troops will not start
firing
at ukrainians today
and go ahead with the offensive it
became useless
48 minutes ago
because about 48 minutes ago your
president declared the war on ukraine
so now i would like to ask the
ambassador of the russian federation to
say on the record
that at this very moment
your troops do not shell
and bomb ukrainian cities
that your troops do not move in the
territory of ukraine
you have a smartphone you can call
lavrov right now
we can make a pose
to let you go out and call him
if you are not in a position
to give an affirmative answer
the russian federation ought to
relinquish
responsibilities
of the president of the security council
past these responsibilities onto a
legitimate member of security council
a member that is respectful of the
charter
and i ask the members of security
council
to convene an emergency meeting
immediately
and consider
all necessary draft decisions all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else